[Music]
it is somewhat surprising I mean we do
you know we love teller she's obviously
one of one of the biggest stars on the
planet the premiere to welcome her video
on the VMAs last year we have really you
know strong you know relationship with
her camp it was amazing video so I wish
I wish she had nominations and I wish
she was here I'm a huge fan MTV's Video
Music Awards bosses addressing Taylor
Swift's video of the year snub she's
such an integral part of of the VMAs MTV
so yes it's tricky
we made sure that all of our core
artists are in the nominee pool it's
voted on you know by a wider rate of
people I think what's interesting is you
know you sometimes you get a different
look if you go into a fan voted
situation so who knows maybe next year
will be fan voted but yeah it's just
listen the dice roll and you never know
twenty-eight-year-old premiered her look
what you made me do video at last year's
VMAs it went on to break the 24-hour
VEVO record and now has nearly a billion
views the vid did score three noms in
smaller categories including best
editing though Taylor's fans on Twitter
were baffled by the video of the Year
snub when the noms came out why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]